from the stern and off to the starboard
side it was a discovery more than 100
years in the making this time using
tools which were unheard of at the time
endurance could endure no more but the
discovery of sir ernest shackleton ship
was a treat for the crew who set out
more than a month ago you can see the
ropes and the rigging uh it's as if it
sank only yesterday shackleton a british
explorer was sent to the antarctic by
his government in the midst of world war
one he set out to make the first
crossing of the continent from the
weddle sea to the rossi but the elements
far too strong with shackleton calling
the waters the most treacherous in the
world
[Music]
the crew on the endurance 22 mission
able to see the vessel thanks to this
underwater search vehicle equipped with
a camera stator pressure preservation is
unbelievable you can see the paint work
it's as good as that it doesn't get any
better it is a beautiful wreck endurance
was found more than three kilometers
below sea level and more than six
kilometers south of where the captain
recorded its position in 1915 the fact
that it looked untouched not surprising
for underwater archaeologists marc-andre
bernier says the water temperature and
oxygen levels help keep organic
materials intact and this is why this is
so
interesting because you do have
captured on the seabed
really a moment that that
that really is a testimony of you know
the exploration of the polls the wreck
is a historic site and is protected so
no organic materials can be collected
but the crew will continue to survey and
gather images of endurance and this
moment putting an end to one chapter in
history there's still so many things to
explore
and and this is just an example of
of the
the wonders of that undersea and perhaps
opening others kyle benning global news